sal was hypnotized
and uh made super bowl predictions he
doesn't know anything about sports but
sal claims his guardian angels help him
predict the future okay and so uh
dr schmiern scott schmiren uh hypnotized
sal
and then sal made predictions
clairvoyant or creep
i feel like my duty is to procreate
you say who will win super bowl win
super bowl number 56
the bengals the bengals great
all right that you were under hypnotism
when you said that right yeah your
guardian angels were telling you this
this wasn't you speaking it was the
guardian angels
that's correct
sal governale mentalist
or mental patient i could communicate
and talk to other forms of energy
without talking
sal says he's going to put up 500 of his
own money on these predictions he's so
convinced that he's right
what will be the final score of the game
what's the final score of the game going
to be
34 42 bengals 34 42 bengals awesome wow
here's some more
sal governali
mystic
or [ __ ]
and confused
who will score first which team is going
to score first
the bengals the bengals are going to
score first
does he know who else is playing
what it is is he probably didn't
remember the la rams but here we go
sal governale
prophet
or pervert i'm complete energy
this is one of the bets what color will
the gatorade be that they dump on the
winning coach what color gatorade will
be poured over the winning head coach's
head
uh greenish yellow
sal governelli
telepathic
or telepathetic the universe is a um a
mission
the universe is a mission that's right
where's john hein john hind give me the
three top ridiculous bets you can make
on super bowl the national anthem one is
is always a good one because you want to
know
how long it's going to go it's the
beginning of the game it kind of gets
you in that betting mode
and uh mickey guyton is doing it this
year and i think the over under is uh
one minute and 37 seconds
and last year it went for over two
minutes so you'd think this is a
no-brainer over but it's it's it's
tricky you never know how it's gonna go
so uh that's a that's a fun crazy one to
start your super bowl betting with give
me uh one or two more ridiculous bets
when you watch the ads i mean there's
always ridiculous bets there and this
year there's uh an over under on
someone appearing in a mask in an ad
uh over what it's one and a half times
so you can bet on how many people show
up in masks during commercials which is
crazy because of the covid crisis how
many commercials will feature a mask
yeah that's one that's one and another
favorite of mine is the they're always
ads with dogs in them so the odds of
dogs appearing in over six and a half
ads is plus 200 but you got to watch the
whole game and make sure you keep track
of every ad to see how many dogs will
appear how many times dogs will appear
in the commercials i'm going to go with
the under on the dogs i see mostly on tv
they're pretending like there is no
culvert or they mention it you see a
character walk in in a mask and then
they quickly take it off i would go yeah
i would go on the under on the uh mass
thing too so i say under on the dogs
under on the masks they have a
censorship bet how many times it'll be
bleeped and it's over under three and a
half on that do you think they told dr
dre and snoop that they can't use foul
language they're gonna be on alert for
it and you know kendrick lamar there are
lots of different performers in this
halftime show eminem so
some of their lyrics already have curse
words in it so i just wonder how they're
going to handle it i i think do you
think eminem will be like hey man [ __ ]
you this is my art i'm not uh changing
lyrics for anybody absolutely if i was a
rapper i would respect that and not use
foul language during my performance
because listen i know up front
it's a super bowl it's being broadcast
and there's nothing worse than when
you're watching musicians on tv and they
bleep the song it just totally [ __ ] the
whole performance up
i would say they should not use foul
language but
knowing these uh guys when i see them on
these award shows and stuff i'm going
with the over on that one for sure yeah
i like the over and one last one howard
i know you got to go there are odds on
whether or not snoop will be smoking on
stage or not snoop will not smoke on
stage that's my prediction that's my 50s
so most people agree with you they think
he will not do it plus 200 if he does
weed is legal in california does that
affect
whether snoop dogg is smoking on i think
he's for sure smoking
for sure
not on stage though i think i think
that's part of the route being a rebel
you smoke on stage you curse i mean
i think for sure he will
don't you want to do the unexpected and
not smoke i believe i really believe i
would take money that that snoop will
not be smoking on stage i agree with you
because he has a lot of endorsement
deals he needs to be seen as somebody
who can be relied upon in a in a given
situation all right well the world gets
sillier and sillier doesn't it
7.6 billion being wagered this year you
could bet on anything with this game
it's crazy